nfl network has reported that the giants
are a possibility now for tom brady and
we have bandied about the possibility of
brady in new york either with the jets
or the giants you've got a guy
in daniel jones second year of his
contract you can tell him take a seat
for tom brady for a year a little bit
awkward a little bit awkward but you got
new coaching staff joe judge the former
patriots assistant tied to tom brady
it's fascinating to think that brady
would do the ultimate if you can't beat
him join a move i know earlier in the
show i talked about the redskins maybe
i'm already moving on from dwayne
haskins i think dwayne haskins and
moving on from him is
totally different than moving on from
someone like daniel jones it would be
temporary wouldn't it wouldn't it be
temporary but
yes it would i i'm just trying to
because you hear these reports right and
then you start trying to connect the
dots
does it make sense like is tom
he's played much better than i think he
was giving credit for last year but
thank you yeah but is is he that much of
a
let's stump the growth of the player
that we selected with a top 10 pick in
daniel jones who had some very promising
moments who's not just this you know
weak arm quarterback that hit throws in
short to intermediate areas no he wants
to attack down the field there's a lot
of good to build on now you can
eliminate eliminate a lot of mistakes
that daniel jones had last year but this
isn't a situation where i think tom
brady would make sense at all would it
for you well here's where tom brady
makes sense and this is a point i've
been making this week it kind of
crystallized for me the other day you
will have the patriots make a football
decision regarding tom brady and that
football decision will drive how much
they're willing to pay him how much can
he help them win and that's bill
belichick's mo he's not going to pay tom
brady a premium because he's good for
business there will be teams out there
that will pay tom brady more
because he's good for business now i
don't know that the giants will view it
that way but this is kind of a fractured
and staggering brand right now and every
team says they want to win
but for a lot of teams the way you win
is with
the almighty dollar ticket sales sweet
sales jersey sales can you imagine a new
york giants tom brady 12 jersey right i
mean no i can't right and that's why
teams like the giants and the raiders
think about tom brady as the la raiders
quarterback
it's it's about dollars and cents it's
about bringing people to las vegas right
so that makes sense right because you
can
the the path that you're creating here
of money in the end again going back to
cba talks that money speaks and building
somewhat of a brand around a new
identity
you have your identity though with the
giants one it's that red and blue it's
saquon barkley and i really think and i
was a major critic of daniel jones
entering the nfl but every time you
watch him there were positives this
isn't a player that you want to stunt
their growth and i don't think daniel
jones is the type that would get upset
by that at all he certainly doesn't seem
like that type of personality but this
is not a situation where okay we know
who we have in derek carr we know what
our ceiling is with him it's not very
high and john gruden constantly is
looking outside the building and being
attracted to other quarterback options i
do not understand the
you know connecting the dots here with
tom brady and the new york giants at all
well
it would be
interesting at least that's what i mean
for them exactly for the for the giants
to finally float eli manning on an
iceberg and go out and sign a free agent
three years older than eli manning it's
just it would be phenomenal i've been
kind of quietly rooting for the cowboys
to get in on this because that would be
the greatest story of all time you love
chaos i love chaos and this is close to
it and who knows maybe the giants are
being leaked to kind of get jerry jones
interest because we were saying
yesterday look okay chargers and raiders
makes business sense for them to want
tom brady doesn't make sense for tom
brady to jump into the afc west with
patrick mahomes as a twice a year
competitor and you're not going to
dominate the division the way you
dominated the afc east you got to go to
the nfc which division is the most
likely for you to dominate well it would
be the nfc east because the nfc stunk
last year they got three new coaches
granted one of them is in dallas but if
jerry jones decides i've had enough of
dak prescott's demands and you know what
he's priced himself out of our league
and no one's going to pay him this kind
of money we'll tag him and we'll trade
him and we'll just pay tom brady and
we'll go all in for one year maybe two
with mike mccarthy in our offensive line
and ezekiel elliott amari cooper in this
defense
they they are they could become good
enough that they could run rough shot
over the division fatten up their record
get the one seed which is going to be
even more important now that they expand
the playoffs and the road to the super
bowl goes through dallas i want these
dominoes to fall though and if the tom
brady domino does fall to a different
team then it sets up a wheel of change
throughout the nfl
that we've never seen before i am
terrified though because i also
want chaos i i want news i like new and
i am a little nervous that everyone's
kind of just going to go back to their
homes the places that they have been
connected to this entire time and then
we're left with you know wherever marcus
mariota goes and obviously up rivers and
at teddy bridgewater and that's as
exciting as it gets even if brady stays
put it's going to be chaotic it's
maximum chaos if he leaves and and i
just think that there will be someone
that from a business standpoint
recognizes the value of tom brady to the
extent that the offer that that team
makes will be dramatically more than
what the patriots offer that bill
belichick look when the report came out
on super bowl sunday that the patriots
are willing to pay tom brady more than
30 million a year yeah robert kraft is
willing to write the check yes but bill
belichick is the guy who's got the purse
strings and if he doesn't want to do it
as a football proposition if he'd rather
spend that 30 million dollars on other
players on the roster and trust jared
stidham or go out and wait for the
dominoes to fall and go bargain shopping
for the guy who's left standing when the
music stops whether it's andy dalton or
whoever that that may be from a and
here's the reason why tom brady's always
taken less
he's not taking less because he's a good
team player he's taken less because he
has always feared this moment where bill
belichick views him as being more
expensive than he's worth and if these
other teams start lining up with 35
million a year or more we think patrick
holmes can be 40 million a year guy
brady could be the first 40 million a
year guy there could be a team out there
that says it's worth it to us to pay it
to him belichick's not going to do it
just that's when and that's when you
leave being down in miami for super bowl
week being here this week it's you know
continuously floated and the worst kept
secret that bill belichick wants to try
his team without tom brady and
the patriot and p people in the patriots
organization are preparing for tom brady
to leave not that he's going to but
they're preparing and you have to look
but that position has to be ready for
that eventuality but there are people
who fear that he's gonna leave and how
do you paint it in a way that you're not
the bad guy in tom brady choosing to
move on but even saying that and you
know we had tom curran on our podcast
back
during our time in miami and he said you
know this decision is going to finally
be bills but i feel like every time we
move closer to the date the decision
date it might not be like it might be a
robert craft injection here that tom
brady is back that's a heck of a risk
because then you've undermined bill
belichick the guy who's got six super
bowl championships it's look he didn't
get involved with bledsoe and there were
some comments recently that were dusted
off from robert craft when they moved on
from drew blood so he didn't like it you
know that you don't allow yourself you
shouldn't allow yourself to get an
emotional attachment to any player
unless you are disciplined enough to say
i'm willing to defer to my coach and let
him make the decision i think robert
craft is we're thinking about this all
from the team perspective what about
from tom brady's perspective what do you
think is most attractive for brady in a
suitor is it offensive line so he
doesn't get hit as often so he plays in
a much cleaner structure is it weapons
is it location what is it do you think i
think it's a bunch of different factors
and i think one of it is he wants to
feel appreciated by bill belichick who's
not wired to do that we were talking the
other night i was talking to somebody
about teddy brewski when he retired and
bill belichick you know he was the
ultimate patriot he
went above and beyond the call did
everything we're running teddy bruce is
like i wish you would have said that to
me once during my career he's just not
wired to do what tom brad i think tom
brady after 20 years wants a little
something from bill belichick that he's
never gotten and i don't think he's ever
going to get it and it's look after the
combine if there isn't a deal done
within a week or so to stay in new
england i think tom brady will be
sitting back waiting for the suitors to
show up he'll have a throne he'll have a
crown and they'll come in one at a time
and they'll try to convince him to
become the newest quarterback of their
team and make them a lot of money along
the way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports